we're gonna continue on that health
threat with a CBS News investigation
that reveals the corona virus has been
especially deadly for one of America's
most vulnerable populations as people in
nursing homes in a disturbing new
development we're learning an
overwhelmed facility in New Jersey put
17 bodies in a morgue that was only big
enough for four Jonathan Vigliotti
reports on these nationwide concerns the
Canterbury rehabilitation and Healthcare
Center in Richmond Virginia is one of
the hardest hit facilities in the
country medical director Jim Wright has
lost 45 residents we have been fighting
a battle with kovat 19 for the past
months now and it is a battle that at
times we feel we're losing it's a grim
scene repeated across the nation
prompting governor's in several states
including Massachusetts and Florida to
deploy the National Guard to run tests
experts say the lack of mandatory
testing for residents and employees
staffing issues and a shortage of
personal protective equipment are the
biggest problems nurse sherry Martinez
asked us not to identify the California
nursing facility where she works
federal officials are also facing
criticism for not publicly tracking
infections and deaths in these
facilities we've reached out to every
state but only got complete data from 19
we also included County data and
information from facilities themselves
officials confirmed more than 35,000
seniors and staff have tested positive
more than 5,700 have died it sounds like
our most vulnerable the elderly are
sitting ducks in these facilities I used
to call the ugly stepsisters of the
healthcare industry because we don't pay
enough attention we don't pay the nurses
aides enough some employees presumably
fearing for their own safety are
refusing to come to work last week at
the Magnolia rehabilitation and nursing
center in Riverside California
one nursing assistant showed up forcing
the county to evacuate 84 residents
Donna Reno's husband Don was a patient
there ambulances lined up ready to you
know cheek everyone out and you know get
them out of that facility
Don Marino tested positive and is now
running a fever I just have to hang in
there and you know hopefully everything
will be good for everybody
Anne Reno tells me after her husband was
evacuated from this facility it actually
took her more than a day to locate him
she had to call the police department
the Centers for Medicare and Medicaid
which oversees nursing homes says it is
now working with the CDC to increase
reporting but how they will do so and
what numbers will be made public at this
point unclear meanwhile Anthony we will
continue to make those calls
state-by-state all right Jonathan thank
you